This matrix vector multiply example
gives us a chance to introduce a couple
of pseudocode shortcuts.
The shortcuts are all based on
expressing operations on arrays
as vector operations.
So you see a hint of that here.
Notice the declaration of
the temporary array t.
I've used this,
what's called vector slicing notation.
That is indexing with a range of values,
in this case 1 to n.
Let's see where else we
can insert that notation.
Let's take a look at this
inner most parfor loop.
What's it doing?
Well, it's basically taking a slice
of this two dimensional matrix and
multiplying it component wise or
element wise with this vector x.
So I can express this parfor loop in a
more compact single line of pseudocode.
So I basically recognize that
all these objects are arrays.
t, A sub i, and x.
The arrays are all of length n.
And they're all indexed
in the range 1 to n.
Now this notation is common in
a bunch of modern languages.
That includes Python,
Matlab and Cray Fortran.
Cray who?
Now if the range is the entire range of
the array object, then we can replace
the explicate range in this case 1 to n,
with just a colon meaning all elements.
So that will give us an even
sightly more compact notation.
Let's go ahead and plug that in.
And of course we're all mature enough
to see that this vector operation
can be easily converted
into a parallel for loop.
So when you are analyzing pseudocode
that includes these kinds of vector
operations, just go ahead and
use the right work and span.
So in particular, these element wise
operations will have linear work and
logarithmic span.
Now we'll allow ourselves to use
a second simplification which is to get
rid of the temporary array.
So it's understood that this element
wise product has to produce a temporary
intermediate element wise result.
Which we then pass to the reduce, so
we can combine these
into a single statement.
Again, the only subtle
thing is that this produces
a bunch of intermediate values.
So that may require a temporary.
So if I ask you to
analyze storage costs,
then you might need to
take that into account.